the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire video
in this video i want to discuss jamie
lannister and ned stark's fight scene
i'm sure all of you remember this
incredible moment from the first season
but if you haven't read the books then
you might not know how different this
scene is in the first book a game of
thrones
over the years the lannisters gave the
starks a lot of reasons not to like them
but i think ned's hatred for the
lannisters mostly dates back to robert's
rebellion
one thing that really disgusted ned that
he has never forgot
was how the lannisters waited until
after rhaegar and his army fell
before they joined their side to end the
mad king's reign
this was something that ned would never
forgive them for
in the game of thrones television show
one of my favorite additions made by dan
and dave was the scene they added
when we see jaime and ned standing
together in the throne room of the red
key
the reason i love this scene is because
it not only displayed ned's feelings for
jaime
but it was also a history lesson that
gave everyone a glimpse of one of the
major events in westeros that did help
create this amazing story as we know it
when i watched the mad king die i
remembered him laughing as your father
burned
it felt like justice
so will you tell yourself at night
you're a servant of justice but you were
avenging my father when you shoved your
sword in aries targaryen's back
i wish i could show you that whole scene
without the video getting flagged but
i'm sure you remember it well
i thought the acting and the dialogue in
that scene was incredible
it showed everyone how far back this
hatred goes as it also gave us a little
more insight into who these characters
are
now what's interesting about the scene i
want to discuss today is it's not in the
books either
well at least not in the way it was
shown in the show
there is a confrontation between ned and
jaime but like i said
it happens very differently in the book
jaime and ned do not actually fight each
other like they did
in the show but i kind of wish they had
i liked how ned and jaime ran into each
other over and over again
exchanging these sort of verbal assaults
that eventually led to bloodshed
the only issue i did have from that
scene in the show was how they made ned
seem almost as good of a swordsman as
jaime based on what we know from the
books
ned stark should not have stood a chance
against the king slayer
i mean after all jaime is said to be one
of the greatest swordsmen in all of the
seven kingdoms
i still thoroughly enjoyed the scene
nonetheless now let me show you how the
scene
ended in the book as you all know
shortly after jaime thrown bran out of
the window
someone set an assassin in his room to
finish off the job but he ended up
losing his life instead
well this assassin had a valyrian steel
dagger
not the sort of dagger your random
assassin would have
whoever wanted bran dead obviously had
some money
[Music]
i don't think bran fell from that tower
i think he was thrown
the boy was always sure footed before
someone tried to kill him twice
did you notice the dagger the killer
used it's too fine a weapon for such a
man
the blade is valerian steel the handle
dragon bone
someone gave it to him
they come into our home and try to
murder my brother
this led to lady catelyn leaving
winterfell for king's landing so she
could investigate
when lady catelyn arrives in king's
landing she has escorted the
littlefinger's brothel where she would
find out who this dagger belonged to
according to littlefinger this was his
dagger only he had lost it over a
gambling debt to tyrion lannister
i bet on sir jaime and the jousting as
any sane man would
when the night of the flowers unseated
him
i lost this dagger to whom
tyrion lannister the imp
this led them to believe tyrion must
have sent the assassin to bran's room
but why would he do that shortly after
this lady catlin just so happens to run
into tyrion lannister
at the end at the crossroads where she
ultimately has him arrested
under the suspicion of attempting to
kill our son
this man came into my house as a guest
and there conspired to murder my son
a boy of ten
in the name of king robert and the good
lords you serve
i call upon you to seize him
and help me return him to winterfell to
await
the king's justice
so then we fast forward a little bit and
we get to the moment where jimmy
lannister confronts ned
over the arrest of his brother during
this scene
littlefinger takes ned stark to a
brothel so he can speak to the mother of
one of robert baratheon's bastards
you see ned stark was in the middle of
his own investigation
he was following all of the last
movements jon aaron made right before
his sudden death
ned was hoping to soon figure out why
john aaron had an interest in all of
robert's bastard children
it would not be long before ned would
realize all of robert's children had his
black hair
yet somehow all the children him and
cersei had together were blonde affair
just like cersei and her brother jaime
lannister
when we see the whole scene in the show
it happens during the day but in the
book
it happens at night during a very heavy
rainstorm
littlefinger ned and his men are soaked
to the bone
as they ride back to the red key there
were rivers of black rainwater running
down the hill when jory called out
my lord his voice was hoarse with alarm
within seconds the street was now full
of lannister soldiers
ned stark immediately noticed all the
men were wearing ring mail over leather
gauntlets and steel helmets with golden
lions on their crest
they were also soaked by the rain water
everything was happening so fast
ned wasn't able to count how many men
were there but he knew there had to be
almost a dozen of them
the soldiers were on foot and blocking
their way while holding long swords and
iron spears in their hands
things were about to get very
interesting behind you
ned heard wild shout and when he turned
his horse around
he saw there were more men behind him
blocking the road to stop them from any
escape
i actually love what it says next jory's
sword came
singing from its scabbard make way or
die
the wolves are howling their leader said
ned saw rain running down the man's face
such a small peck though littlefinger
walked his horse forward
step by careful step what is the meaning
of this
this is the hand of the king he was the
hand of the king
the mud muffled the hooves of the
blood-based stallion
the soldiers in the street stepped aside
and made way before him
on a golden breastplate the lion of
lannister roared its defiance
now if truth be told i'm not sure what
he is
lannister this is madness littlefinger
said let us through
we are expected back at the castle what
do you think you're doing
oh he knows what he's doing ned said
calmly
jaime lannister smiled quite true i'm
looking for my brother
you remember my brother don't you lord
stark he was with us at winterfell
fair-haired mismatched eyes sharp of
tongue
a short man i remember him well ned
replied
it would seem he has met some trouble on
the road my lord father is not very
happy about this
would you have any notion of who might
want to wish my brother ill
your brother has been taken at my
command to answer for his crimes
ned stark said littlefinger groaned in
dismay
my lords sir jaime then ripped his
longsword from its sheath and urged his
stallion forward
show me your steel lord eddard i'll
butcher you like the mad king if i must
but i'd sooner you die with a blade in
your hand then he gave littlefinger an
arrogant glance
and said i'd leave here fast if i did
not care to get bloodstains on my
expensive clothing
he did not need to urge littlefinger who
said i will bring the city watch he
swore to ned
the lion of lannister soldiers moved out
of the way to let him through
but then they closed in behind him
littlefinger vanished almost immediately
ned's men had drawn their swords but
they were greatly outnumbered
almost seven to one eyes were watching
them from nearby windows and doors
but no one was about to intervene all of
ned's men were still on their horses
while jaime's men were on foot except
for jaime who was still on the back of
his stallion
ned considered charging on their horses
right through the men on foot
but he thought he had a better way to
handle this without running
so ned warned the kingslayer if you kill
me
my wife will most certainly slay your
brother tyrion
jaime lannister shoved his gilded sword
right into ned's chest
the same sword that stepped on the blood
of the last of the dragon kings
the mad king aerys targaryen would she
the noble catelyn talley of riverrun
murder a hostage
i think not but i'm not willing to
chance my brother's life on a woman's
honor
jaime slid the golden sword back into a
sheath then he says
i guess i will let you run back to
robert so you can tell him about how i
frightened you
i wonder if he'll care jaime threw back
his wet hair with his fingers and
wheeled his horse
around when he was beyond the line of
swordsman he glanced back at his captain
he says make sure no one hurts lord
stark
as you say my lord even through the
night in the rain
ned could see the white of jaime smile
as he said
kill his men no ned stark screamed
reaching for his sword jaime was already
out of sight by the time he heard wild
shout
jaime's men closed in from all sides ned
stark rode one of them down
cutting at phantoms and red cloaks who
gave way before him
jory castle began to charge on his horse
a steel shod hoof caught a lannister
guardsman in the face with a sickening
crunch
a second man reeled away and for an
instant jory was free
wile was cursing as they yanked him off
his dying horse
sword slashing in the rain ned stark
galloped over to him
bringing his longsword down on the
lannister soldier's helmet
the jolt of the impact made him grit his
teeth the man stumbled to his knees
his lion crest sheared in half blood
running down his face
one of ned's men was hacking at the
hands that had seized his bridle
but then a spear caught him right in the
belly suddenly jory was back among them
a red rain flying from his sword no
ned shouted jory away nedsaur slipped
under him and came crashing down in the
mud
there was a moment of blinding pain and
the taste of blood in his mouth
he saw them cut the legs out from under
jory's horse and dragged him to the
earth
swords rising and falling as they closed
in around him when ned's horse large
back to his feet
he tried to rise only to fall again
choking on his scream
he could see the splintered bone
sticking out of his calf
it was the last thing he saw for a time
the rain came down and down and down
when he opened his eyes again lord
eddard stark was alone
with his dead his horse moved closer
caught the ranked scent of blood
and galloped away ned stark began to
drag himself through the mud
gritting his teeth at the agony in his
leg it seemed to take years
faces were watching from candlelit
windows and people began to emerge from
the alleys and doors
but none of them came to help
littlefinger in the city watch found him
there in the street
cradling jory castle's body in his arms
somewhere the gold cloaks found a litter
but the ride back to the castle was a
blur of agony and ned lost consciousness
more than once
he remembered seeing the red keep
looming ahead of him in the first gray
light of dawn
the rain had darkened the stone of the
massive walls to the color of blood
this chapter ends right as it says then
grand maester pycelle was looming over
him
holding a cup whispering drink my lord
hear the milk of the poppy for your pain
he remembered swallowing
and pycelle was telling someone to heat
the wine to a boil
and fetch him some clean silk and that
was the last that ned
knew now you can see how different this
scene was in the book
although jaime did give the order he did
not shed any blood himself
he did not jam a dagger into jory's eye
nor did he fight ned stark at all
ned wasn't even injured by one of the
lannister guards like he was in the show
when they stuck the spear through the
back of his leg in the book version
ned breaks his leg when him and his
horse go crashing into the ground
now like i was saying before i think i
like the way the show did this better
i like that we were able to see ned and
jaime get their hands dirty
i know i was anxious to see jaime fight
considering how everyone said he was
this amazing swordsman
the only issue i had with it is they
went a little overboard by having ned
hold his own against jaime
if we're to believe he is as good as
they say he is then he should have won
that easily
i'm fine with it overall though this is
one of those instances where i like the
book version
and i like the show version let me know
if there are any other scenes you would
like to see done in a video format
next i already have several in mind but
if there is a scene you always wanted to
know how it was done in the books versus
the show then let me know down below
i can add that to my list as always i
want to thank everyone for watching
also if you want to get early access to
these videos consider joining my patreon
account
that link is in the description have a
great day everyone i will see you again
very soon
bye
[Music]
you